hier oder da was geht ab hier soll max
und herz willkommen zu dieser runde sky
wars zusammenstoß hatte das ende hätte
ich muss schnell die mitte tut mir leid
sturm basti ist okay du hast musst du
okay ich habe ganz aber bleiben du bist
dann recht bleibt ruhig obwohl ich uns
das gute zeug aus der mitte wir wollten
gerade eigentlich dieses speed bilder
sting aufnehmen aber das ist komplett
überrannt und lieberman
es hat einfach nicht funktioniert oder
nicht funktioniert oder wollte noch mal
sagen danke hey hey ich hab diese
gemeine sachen wo bist du
ich bin ein kenner von uns dass unsere
insel natürlich wieder auf irgendeine
gegangen jetzt meine daneben aber fast
durch machine bist du zu mir kommt rüber
in berlin gleich erledigt einfach die
gegner hier soweit ich durch über m lg
wenn sie das kannst dann los die rabatte
guck ich mache es jetzt da und da muss
man eine steile tun wo man hin will der
falsche richtung nein nein nein du musst
das tmt das dritte musst du hinter die
platzieren hinter direkt lassen
so fließt jetzt auf da ins nichts
aber egal kann ich regel das lampions
verstanden was ich kann dass man hört
das schon wenn man sieht dass er ich
habe schon geregelt ich hab das team
schon fertig mit dem computer und
schwimmen jetzt kannst du müsstest die
forscherin aber du machst drei stücken
ja genau so genau okay ich kann ihr
keinen ich kenne keine dick setzen
nebel sturm kommt das ist so wie ich da
kommt einer zu dir
das einfach schlimm hatte ok da will ich
hin
im ccn tnt ist aber überlebt kraft jetzt
warte nun gespannt ich komme ja sturm -
hoch springen auf den block hoch nein
nein
das ist einfach energie als nicht neben
händel aber ich hab' ich hab das wasser
gesetzt doch was gut oder
aber ich rede dann war es wichtig eine
maschine ich muss nur noch schreien dann
hat mir gefallen dann probiert aber
allein machen du kannst mir ja total
unterstützen nicht fix unterstützt
unterstützt gerne fix wir sind noch vier
spieler sind die allen ein logischer wp
23 feier er das ist der echte dass man
essen leute was sind das hier für zu
stellen was haben jetzt dafür im team
partner überhaupt besorgt ich werde es
auch dieses mal ging noch mal probieren
einmal hatte ich ja schon relativ
erfolgreich gemacht in dem video was ich
gemacht habe aber sonst auch überhaupt
nie ausprobiert auch nur deshalb kann
ich nichts versprach das sind meistens
leider nichts machen ich habe keine
blöcke ich weiß nicht ob ich die
weggeworfenen gerade wahrscheinlich aber
es ist richtig richtig doof dass ich
keine röcke habe aber da oben gibt es ja
diesen dieses ärgert mich weil so ist
uns wirklich hand einer vorbauen auf die
paar metern dann benutze ich meine
ändert werde weil das dürfte ja echt
gehen wird soll ich probieren die wahl
mit dem tmt die public und entsprechend
in den wasserfall weil ich keinen bock
haben jetzt irgendwie abzubauen
wenn ich jetzt nicht lange dann wirds
echt peinlich okay das wäre richtig
richtig richtig richtig richtig richtig
richtig oft richtig richtig oft richtig
oft peinlich gewesen
ja da kommen diese tollen mm gegner
banden ob ich sie besiegen kann seht ihr
wenn ihr montierten toren quartal gute
besserung spd ist unsere pace dass
schumi debakel begonnen hat sie
beschließt er sich jetzt dahin dann
finde ich den cool auch wenn er logisch
dass du sehr imagemäßig in der
zwischenzeit ich bin geil finden die
gasse oder geflogen ich guck mir dass
alle am liebsten noch höchst
konzentriert da überlegen wie ich die
gegner also übertrieben
ok es doch kult und jetzt schaue ich mms
das kann ja nicht sein dass jetzt war
ich habe einfach keine block herum ich
da irgendwie dran zu bauen
du hast bei dem drang ja ich war dass
ich war toll als ob das jetzt nicht wahr
ist nicht immer wirklich fenster
aber dieser eine typ studie ist gestoppt
in seinem rb7 ist der typ ist gestorben
wegen seinem energy wurst und der ist
gerade wegen john cena oder mit der
hilfe gestorben also
gut wenn man wenn man gewinnen will was
dann sollte man sich das glaube ich mir
überlegen ob man das macht wenn man
schließe perfektioniert hat aber ich
würde sagen ja lieb hab ich es gewonnen
ok dann dankeschön leute und bist du
schön übrigens ich war ich war sehr
lange dabei hat spaß im kino bis zur
nächsten